oh my god am I trying to be cute it's
trying to be cute effortlessly desperate
hi guys name is for somebody do not know
now you know your life is different now
I totally forgot to make a favorites
video for September that doesn't really
change the course of the world so here's
an October favorites here are some
things I'd like to slightly more than
other things this month let's get into
it
yeah this is brow stylist Freeman set
from L'Oreal Paris this is a brow gel
King thrilling I like looking for new
brow products cuz they seem to make them
constantly and I constantly am looking
for a different way to procrastinate
from getting any work done yeah and I
bought this at like a CVS just randomly
and I really like it it's brow gel that
comes with this stick that's a spoolie
on one end and then a little pointy guy
on the other makeup terms sorry if
they're going over your head and it's a
bright brow gel I mean there's nothing
really special about it I think I really
like it because I think I got the right
color for my eyebrows finally so this
might be a very average product but I
think it's [ __ ] great cuz it matches
the hair that's it cute okay okay I'll
say it I yeah so yeah this is NYX dark
circle concealer corrector this is an
under-eye dark circle concealer I just
said basically the same thing twice yay
I'm always looking for a good under-eye
concealer because I don't sleep properly
and I look like I raged too hard and I
really want to trick people into
thinking I'm balanced and this helps me
do it basically there's a little tub of
enabling thank you something's making
weird noise in my home we'll do what we
do with anything that's weird in our
lives
ignore it I've been using NARS under-eye
concealer for a while and that stuff's
really expensive to replace and this is
NYX so you can get it in a drugstore and
it's really cheap and it works really
really well it allows me to walk into a
room and have people have to speculate
about the mistakes I made last night
instead of automatically know that I've
made some mistakes last night yeah this
is a blush from NARS I've had this in my
makeup case for ever and I cleaned out a
ton of my stuff over the weekend and I
thought this was gonna be NARS
or
awesome that blush it like every beauty
guru used to like all the time and then
I opened it I realize it's not instead
it's called guru I am NOT making that up
it's called guru this is the name of it
it's this really kind of darker plummy
color that feels like very autumnal and
airy fall and I like it a lot and I had
no idea I had it all so it's in this
really cute pint-sized travel-size case
which makes it easy to just throw in my
makeup bag and take it on my worldly
excursions I'm well traveled in my brain
I like to be home all the time cute next
okay I'll see ya so yeah no it's not an
adorable travel sized vibrator
it is a mascara it's covered girls total
tease mascara and here's the deal the
reason this is in the favorites video is
not necessarily because this is a great
mascara but because it's got a great
gimmick going for it check this out it's
a mascara and the wand has one side
that's for applying the mascara I like
normal and then another side that has
this teeny tiny little comb thing that's
meant to tease the roots of your
eyelashes it's completely unnecessary
but I've seen love gimmicks and so I
bought into this immediately at CVS does
it do anything better than a regular
mascara not necessarily but the little
prickly stick teasing comb does help
separate the lashes so that part is kind
of helpful but other than that total
gimmick probably total waste of money
but totally satisfying in my dumbass
brain you next can't see okay I'll say
it I'll say this is Evan Healey the skin
breathes lemon thyme facial tonic hydro
Sol for all skin especially oily blemish
and/or teen didn't have no teen skin was
a separate category of skin and
something about that it's very perverted
so let's gloss over that and continue on
this is a facial tonic does it do for
your face the [ __ ] if I know but I like
it it's lemon time so it smells really
really refreshing and really good I
spray it on my face before I put makeup
on and then
after I take my makeup off before I go
to bed no clue what it does let me be
your dermatologist when I spray it it
makes my skin feel kind of stinging and
I always feel like if something stings
and it's probably doing something good
it's like when you have sex for the
first time let me be your health teacher
it makes my skin feel tighter makes uh
skin feel brighter that might be a lie I
don't even know it just stings and feels
tight so it's great next yeah yeah say
yeah yeah say yeah
can you please this is a candle I have
no idea where I got this candle but it's
in my house I have a feeling this was
gifted to me by someone if you're
watching this video and you gifted me
this candle thank you I'm really great
at remembering sentimental moments
between myself and my loved ones this is
from a company called Apothic e apo th e
ke in brooklyn and it's a in cho town i
don't know what that word is charcoal so
basically it smells like charcoal and
it's really fragrant I love this smell
smells like a campfire it's a small
candle but it's super potent so you can
light it for a little bit and it just
infuses the room with smell of camping
and charcoal and you can blow it out
pretty quickly and still have that scent
linger which is really great so you get
a lot of use out of it get the pseudo
experience of camping without having to
leave the safety and privacy of your own
home when kinguin and for grace Helbig
Thank You Kendall these favorites videos
has just become a collection of things
that enable me to introverted ly rage my
own home to excess fun mask Casey Casey
is another tangible thing that you can
see but it's a youtube series
it's the trying I always on BuzzFeed
video I know I'm super late to this
train but I am finally on board they've
been around for years and years and
years but I went into a deep wormhole
for the first time of their videos a few
weeks ago and I'm obsessed it's for guys
they're really funny they're kind of
dorky but they're very self-aware and
they're really good friends and they
just try things and they usually kind of
fail or they usually struggle and it's
fun to watch other people fail and
struggle they also just excessively use
BuzzFeed's money in their videos and
openly talk about wasting company money
which makes me laugh also I think the
four of them are coming on to my podcast
not too deep into sets of two so I have
two episodes with try guys coming up
soon
if you didn't know I do a podcast called
not too deep you can watch full episodes
on full screen you can listen for free
on soundcloud and itunes and this week
the gabbie show gabby hannah is on for
her third year in a row by notice it's a
really exciting episode she's on for the
third year of our Halloween special in a
row and she has insane amounts of ghost
stories that are so creepy you have to
listen to it it's really great go check
that out if you haven't already
that was a tangent they awesome from
chagas try them out they're great last
can you see it you'll see you can't see
it this adorably fashion-forward yet at
the same time extremely timeless hoodie
from me if you didn't know I have these
limited edition I don't know hoodies
available at broker feel calm such I
don't know link will be in the
description below there's like two days
left of the campaign and you guys have
already bought like over 2000 of them
which is crazy but time's running out so
make sure if you want one get them
because they're going in the garbage
when the campaign is done there's five
colors to choose from red navy blue
forest green grey and black so I'll go
check those out they're very comfortable
they make you relatable approachable and
sociable no guarantees that's it for
this favorites video give it a thumbs up
if you enjoy favorites videos and make
sure you subscribe to this YouTube
channel I make videos Monday Wednesday
and Friday sometimes and sometimes I
change things that look go wild this
thing if you want to make sure you don't
miss a second of the wild click the bell
notifications so you get notified when
the videos go up because it's it could
be at any time any day or not at all
forever who knows I don't know